- [Voiceover] Those are enormous.
- [Voiceover] Jesus Christ.
I wore JNCO Jeans for an entire week
and this is what happened.
JNCO Jeans came out in
the mid to late 90s.
They fit you normally at the very top
and then they get incredibly
baggy at the bottom.
I always thought JNCO Jeans
were really interesting
and something drew me to them,
and I could never wear them
because I went to a Catholic middle school
where I had to wear a uniform.
(rock music)
It was a weird feeling at first.
Literally couldn't believe
how large they were.
It felt like you were
wearing a denim comforter.
What did I do?
I got used to the swishing noise
and the very slight breeze
that were to go up my legs.
The pockets were interesting.
- [Voiceover] Meat pocket.
- They were great, they
were relatively functional.
You could fit anything in there,
you could probably fit a small child.
I just put my entire laptop in
the back pocket of my pants.
Tuesday was just bad.
The pants drag.
When they get wet, it's like
you're wearing a puddle.
Well, my pants finally
got stuck on something.
My pants got caught on sewer grates.
I tripped on this.
I avoided escalators at all costs.
They terrify me to begin with.
Wearing JNCO's on top of that,
there was no chance.
The initial rush of wearing
the pants has worn out.
People were really,
blatantly staring at me.
When I woke up on Wednesday
I just decided that I was gonna go for it.
If people were gonna
look at me on the streets
then I might as well give
them something to look at.
So I put on a bucket hat
and a Crystal Pepsi t-shirt,
and I just went all out with my 90's look.
It felt pretty liberating, it was great.
I really enjoyed it actually.
I just really didn't care what
anyone else thought anymore.
So I was feeling great after Wednesday,
and I wake up Thursday and
I'm talking to my girlfriend
before we leave the
apartment to go to work.
And she tells me that she
has a work happy hour,
and then immediately remembered
that I was wearing JNCO Jeans all week
and immediately disinvited me.
My girlfriend just texted me that
I seriously should not show
up to her work happy hour.
I realized that the experiment had gotten
a little out of control.
(rock music)
I was happy to be wearing
them for one last day.
- I love your pants.
- Thanks so much.
I was reflecting on the entire week.
My friend got tickets for
the Big East Tournament.
It was this celebration
of getting through it all.
It felt like they were
throwing a party for me,
even though there was a
basketball game going on.
Then I realized coming out
of Madison Square Garden
that I had to take escalators.
(rock music)
I get to the top of the
escalator and I just, I jumped.
And I was okay.
It was definitely like a
culmination of the whole week.
It was this celebration
of getting though it all.
I would recommend to anybody to wear
JNCO Jeans for a week.
I think it's a great exercise
in stripping away your ego,
and really just trying
something different,
and living in someone else's pants.
(upbeat music)